Trascrizione: Chiara Miniaci
Revisore: Michele Gianella
"Al cielo non chiedo altro
che una casa piena di libri
e un giardino pieno di fiori."
Dove pensereste di essere,
guardando queste immagini?
Un bel giardino, due statue,
un palazzo storico?
Sono Lavinia Manfrotto,
e assieme alle mie sorelle,
Lorenza e Veronica,
gestisco una libreria -
e sono un po' emozionata.
Grazie!
(Applausi)
Una libreria particolare,
come potrete vedere:
il portone si apre sull'androne,
dal soffitto altissimo;
una scala ci accompagna al mezzanino,
e quindi al piano nobile,
affrescato con le storie
di Antonio e Cleopatra.
Una libreria che avrebbe
dovuto essere la nostra casa.
C'è anche un'altra
caratteristica importante:
è stata arredata proprio
come se fosse stata la nostra casa,
con mobili in noce, tavolini, poltrone.
Il palazzo è importante:
noi volevamo che chi entrava in libreria
potesse sentirsi a suo agio,
che si sentisse come a casa.
"Quale impresa tenteresti,
se fossi certo di non fallire? "
Ecco: forse, proprio aprire una libreria,
anche se non è stata una nostra scelta.
Successivamente al rogito,
e a nostra insaputa,
è stato posto su Palazzo Roberti
un vincolo di destinazione d'uso
che ne imponeva un unico utilizzo:
una libreria.
Che cosa fareste, se vi ritrovate
con un palazzo enorme,
con il progetto dei vostri sogni
per restaurarlo;
e invece, potete usarlo
solo come libreria?
Come vi sentireste, se vostro padre
tornasse a casa e vi dicesse:
"Faremo una libreria,
e sarà una libreria bellissima.
E voi, ragazze, mi darete una mano"?
Voi, ragazze, avete 18, 21, 24 anni -
chiaramente, non in questa fotografia -
e non siete neanche delle lettrici.
Come vi sentireste, se foste catapultate
in un mondo piuttosto chiuso,
come quello dei librai dell'epoca,
il più delle volte attempati,
convinti di essere i detentori del sapere,
e di non volerlo certo condividere
con tre sbarbatelle?
Cosa fareste?
Vi rimbocchereste le maniche
e cerchereste di imparare,
perché non c'è altra possibilità.
"L'incontro casuale con un libro
può cambiare il destino di un'anima".
L'incontro con questo palazzo,
il cui destino era quello
di diventare una libreria,
ha fatto nascere in noi una passione
che non pensavamo di avere.
Il libro è un oggetto affascinante:
ogni libro è diverso.
E ogni libro può dare risposte diverse
a seconda di chi lo legge.
I lettori sono il bene più prezioso
che ogni libreria possa avere.
In particolare, una libreria
non può essere un negozio che vende libri;
ma deve essere un luogo fisico,
in cui la gente viene
anche solo per incontrarsi,
per sfogliare le novità appena arrivate,
per sedersi in giardino a godersi il Sole
in attesa di scegliere il libro giusto.
E voi sarete lì, per dargli tutto questo.
"Non c'è uomo più riconoscente
di quello a cui si è dato proprio il libro
che la sua anima desiderava":
Allora, abbiamo un palazzo bellissimo,
arredato come un salotto di casa.
Ora bisogna imparare
a dare il libro giusto
alle persone che entrano.
E per farlo, bisogna soprattutto leggere.
È importante non fermarsi
alle critiche letterarie,
ma leggere personalmente i libri,
perché può esserci una pagina o una frase,
in un libro meraviglioso,
che lo possono rovinare.
O potrebbe esserci una frase meravigliosa,
che può rendere bellissimo
un libro mediocre.
I clienti devono sentirsi consigliati,
come faremmo con i nostri familiari:
sanno che non daremo mai loro
un libro sgradevole.
O almeno, proviamoci.
Bisogna creare occasioni
per portare la gente in libreria:
gli incontri con l'autore,
la nostra rassegna "Resistere",
sono l'esempio più grande
di ciò che il mondo del libro
può donare ad un individuo.
La condivisione di emozioni
ci può aiutare ad affrontare
i problemi, grandi e piccoli,
che la vita ci pone davanti.
E chi meglio di uno scrittore
ci può aiutare, in questo?
"Una stanza senza libri
è come un corpo senza anima".
Ecco la vera magia del libro:
quella di suscitare emozioni
che possono essere positive,
costruttive, motivanti;
ma anche negative, irritanti.
Un libro non è nulla, se non è visto
attraverso gli occhi di chi lo legge.
Siamo noi, che diamo voce ai libri;
e ci vuole un posto speciale,
per contenere tutte queste emozioni.
E voi farete in modo
che la vostra sete possa contenerle.
"Usa il tuo talento, qualunque esso sia.
I boschi sarebbero
terribilmente silenziosi,
se cantassero solo gli uccelli
che cantano meglio".
In qualche modo,
questo palazzo ha tirato fuori di noi
un talento che non pensavamo di avere.
Noi eravamo nate tra tubi
di alluminio e morsetti:
il papà costruiva
attrezzature fotografiche.
La sua più grande eredità
è stata quella di trasmetterci
il senso del lavoro.
Qualsiasi cosa tu faccia, falla al meglio:
mettici l'anima, non farti abbattere,
costruisci, trasforma, reagisci.
Altre difficoltà erano in agguato:
la crisi del 2012, per esempio.
Si piange, ci si rammarica;
e poi si reagisce.
Cosa fare? Ho pochi soldi.
Cosa si può fare in una libreria,
con un budget ridotto?
Bisogna ripensare gli spazi
della libreria,
e il proprio ruolo di librai.
Bisogna, se possibile,
aumentare il numero
degli incontri con gli autori,
organizzare dei pomeriggi
dedicati ai bambini.
Abbiamo la Letta:
possiamo organizzare delle merende
dove possano giocare in giardino.
Facciamogli fare
quello che facciamo a casa:
la pasta all'uovo;
i biscotti di pasta frolla;
le letture animate.
Devono sentirsi come a casa.
"Quando ero piccolo, da grande
volevo diventare un libro".
La narrativa per bambini
sta quasi raggiungendo, per vendite,
la narrativa per gli adulti.
Bisogna creare, per i bambini,
un luogo speciale.
Sotto ogni finestra
posizioniamo una panca,
dove si possano sedere e sfogliare i libri
come farebbero i grandi.
I tavolini facciamoli bassi,
alla loro altezza,
in modo che si possano servire da soli.
E se gli scappa la pipì?
Facciamo un bagnetto solo per loro.
Decoriamolo con le immagini
dei cartoni animati.
Dipingiamo delle sedie,
e attacchiamole al muro,
o posizioniamoci dei libri.
Mettiamo anche un metro, sulla porta,
dove si possano misurare:
devono sentirsi a casa.
Montiamo anche un fasciatoio per le mamme,
così che possano cambiare i loro neonati.
Deve diventare il loro luogo del cuore.
Non devono essere intimiditi
dall'entrare in una libreria.
"Un giorno lessi un libro
e tutta la mia vita cambiò".
Ecco, la vera magia del libro:
la possibilità di creare
delle connessioni.
Una volta arredata,
la libreria non potrà rimanere
come l'abbiamo pensata,
ma bisogna stupire il cliente.
Cambiamo la disposizione dei mobili;
aggiungiamo piante;
appendiamo dei quadri.
Abbiamo un caminetto?
spostiamoci dei ceppi di legno.
Non lo possiamo accendere,
siamo in una libreria?
Non importa: creerà
una sensazione di calore.
Chi entra in questa libreria,
chi entra nel vostro negozio,
deve sentirsi abbracciato.
Deve venire anche soltanto
per sentirsi al sicuro.
In questo ambiente incontrerà voi:
librai sorridenti,
estremamente preparati e disponibili.
Pronti per consigliare il libro
che potrebbe cambiare la loro vita.
"Lo so, figlia mia,
che non ti lascio in eredità
beni e ricchezze;
ma ti insegno a leggere i libri.
Quando un uomo sente
farsi oscuro intorno a lui,
legge un libro e vede un altro mondo".
In Italia si legge molto meno
che in altri paesi europei:
e questo è un vero peccato,
perché un libro può diventare
un consigliere, o un amico fidato.
Attraverso un gesto
apparentemente semplice,
come quello di leggere,
si possono vedere mondi inarrivabili,
si possono conoscere personaggi storici.
Si può diventare un agente segreto,
una cortigiana seducente.
Ci si può intrufolare
in un rapporto tra madre e figlia,
sentendoci la madre o la figlia.
Si possono creare delle connessioni
che non avremmo mai immaginato.
Il libro è un bene
che dona ad ognuno
una visione del mondo diversa.
Portare a casa un libro
ci fa viaggiare tra continenti
restando seduti sul divano di casa.
"Ho cercato ovunque la felicità,
ma non l'ho trovata da nessuna parte
se non in un piccolo angolo
con un piccolo libro".
Voi vorrete che la vostra libreria
possa essere quel piccolo angolo,
con un piccolo libro,
dove trovare la felicità.
(Applausi)